[Música]
y culminó en Suiza la llamada Cumbre
global sobre la Inteligencia artificial
al Servicio del bien y en la que un
grupo de humanoides ofreció una
conferencia de prensa la primera de este
tipo en la historia durante el evento
estos robots reflexionaron sobre varios
temas y es precisamente lo que
analizaremos a continuación para ello
vamos a conectar con María Paz
hermosilla ella es directora de
laboratorio de innovación pública de la
universidad Adolfo Ibáñez bienvenida a
France 24 primero por qué la necesidad
de este nombre Inteligencia artificial
para el bien
muchas gracias Valentina por la
invitación en realidad lo que se busca
remarcar con este nombre que es como una
especie de marca No es cierto título es
que la Inteligencia artificial esta
tecnología que emula no es cierto el el
como los humanos tomamos decisiones se
puede usar para el bien común no
solamente para el interés particular o
el interés de una empresa no es cierto
para para las ganancias de una empresa
sino para resolver problemas de la
humanidad que en el caso de las Naciones
Unidas están plasmados No es cierto en
los objetivos de desarrollo sostenible
por ejemplo la reducción de la
mortalidad materna la reducción de la
hambruna y distintos otros objetivos que
todos consideramos que son como el bien
común eso es básicamente lo que se
quiere decir cuando se habla de
Inteligencia artificial para el bien
bueno llama la atención escuchar esta
conferencia de prensa donde quienes
hablan son Realmente robots que nos dice
el hecho de estar escuchando y de tener
en cuenta lo que dice un robot sobre
determinados temas sobre el mundo y
sobre este momento en los desarrollos
tecnológicos
yo creo que esto tiene que ver un poco
no cierto con esto de querer hacer
noticia demostrar una cosa novedosa Por
qué se reúnen los periodistas bueno en
los últimos seis meses con la irrupción
de los modelos de la Inteligencia
artificial generativa o que genera en
este caso lenguaje no cierto como chat
gpt u otros se se ha descubierto que la
Inteligencia artificial ahora puede
hacer cosas más nuevas que no sabíamos y
esto genera por supuesto como como un
interés No es cierto es una novedad y y
llamar la atención de los medios de
comunicación en esta época es difícil
por lo tanto si juntamos a varios robots
y les hacemos que hablen vamos a nos van
a prestar atención o sea es básicamente
yo creo que las personas asisten o
prestan atención porque dicen bueno que
Quién me podrá O sea qué novedad voy a
encontrar acá por qué Porque los últimos
seis meses me he visto sorprendido por
lo que la Inteligencia artificial puede
hacer yo creo que de ahí viene esta este
interés bueno algo que llama la atención
y que ya se está discutiendo por ejemplo
en la unidad europea son estas
regulaciones que han pedido no solo
personas que de alguna manera se oponen
sino los mismos padres y los mismos
creadores de la Inteligencia artificial
qué podemos decir de este tipo de
peticiones una regulación global es
posible es factible
Bueno hay hay temáticas No es cierto
donde el mundo sí se ha puesto de
acuerdo pensemos por ejemplo en en Las
Armas nucleares en donde los países se
han puesto de acuerdo en que es algo
negativo y han ido tratando de
desescalar no cierto los arsenales
nucleares de los distintos países o sea
sí tenemos ejemplos en donde el mundo se
pone de acuerdo los mismos objetivos de
desarrollo sostenible ahora de que eso
se pueda hacer como un informe no cierto
o sea como que se pueda fiscalizar
realmente ese es otro otro tema es pero
es muy relevante que que podamos
discutir sobre la Inteligencia
artificial y que los países sí le puedan
poner ciertas reglas en caso de La
regulación europea Hay ciertos casos por
ejemplo de uso de la Inteligencia
artificial que se declaran como
prohibidos y en el caso de la Unión
Europea se va a crear un organismo No es
cierto que hay que ayudaría a gobernar
esto a nivel de Europa y con organismos
de los distintos países y por ejemplo
Qué usos manipular a las personas ya
otros usos que son prohi es el uso del
reconocimiento facial en vivo ya como en
ciertos lugares para vigilar pero en
vivo no por ejemplo para investigar el
delito que eso ya no sería un uso en
vivo es es importante reconocer que la
Inteligencia artificial puede tener
efectos que no son los deseados puede
afectar nuestros derechos humanos pero
también puede hacer mucho bien entonces
por eso debemos tratar de usarla de una
manera responsable en Chile nosotros
estamos trabajando con el gobierno de
chile con distintos organismos públicos
por ejemplo la agencia de compras
públicas y hemos sacado regulaciones de
Cómo comprar Inteligencia artificial en
enero de este año se publicó en Chile
una regulación por parte de la agencia
de compras públicas que rige para todos
los organismos públicos del país y que
incluye estándares de transparencia de
protección de datos de no discriminación
de responsabilidad Entonces se puede
trabajar con los gobiernos para avanzar
en distintos niveles de regulación yo
creo que sí Ahora si Tratamos de tener
una a nivel global y que se pueda
hacer como fiscalización y que hayan
sanciones a nivel global yo creo que nos
vamos a demorar pero sí vamos a ir
avanzando de a poco y y es importante
también que haya conciencia de las
mismas empresas de y de los y de los
consumidores de cuando se puede o no
usar Inteligencia artificial para algo
bueno en medio de los temores que genera
lo desconocido como es la Inteligencia
artificial para muchas personas y que
los humanos podamos llegar a ser
reemplazados por esta tecnología pues se
le preguntó a los humanoides si podrían
asumir responsabilidades políticas o
incluso dirigir estados y uno de ellos
respondió que los robots tienen un mayor
nivel de efectividad que los líderes
globales Qué opinión merece esto
yo creo que en este minuto los robots
pueden hacer tareas muy específicas y
concretas y las pueden hacer bien el
liderazgo de una nación o de una
institución es una tarea bastante
compleja que
yo dudo que un robot en este minuto
pueda hacer cosas que los robots pueden
hacer bien por ejemplo en chile hay una
empresa que usa robots para ver qué
productos faltan en las repisas de los
supermercados y luego diseña Rutas para
los reponedores de mercancía Y eso lo
hace de manera eficiente Y estos robots
por ejemplo trabajan en la noche dejan
todo listo y en la mañana el reponedor
puede poner la mercancía son cosas
concretas específicas tareas que tienen
bordes pero el liderazgo por ejemplo
requiere empatía requiere
requiere hay situaciones inesperadas
pensemos en la pandemia nosotros estos
robots hay que entrenarlos con datos
históricos para que sepan cómo
reaccionar Entonces es imposible creo yo
o sea veo muy muy difícil ese escenario
en donde un robot sea un mejor líder que
un humano pero sí veo escenarios en
donde el robot puede hacer cosas
específicas muy bien pero el liderazgo
no es es una es una habilidad mucho más
compleja por decirlo así que reponer
mercancía no es cierto en un en una
repisa Entonces yo en ese sentido sería
un poquito excauta estos robots han sido
entrenados en modelos de lenguaje que
incluyen por supuesto películas de
ciencia ficción y entonces van a Van a
responder digamos lo que lo que esté por
decirlo así en el conocimiento que que
se usó para entrenarlos en el mundo que
se sacó de internet y en ese sentido
Creo que todavía no está la tecnología
como para para esa para decir esa esas
afirmaciones pues María Paz a usted
muchas gracias por su análisis y por
compartirlo con nosotros en France 24
Gracias a ustedes por la invitación y a
ustedes gracias por su sintonía volvemos
en unos momentos con más aquí en directo
América
[Música]